im geschäftigen alltag in kamishli
deutet wenig darauf hin dass der krieg
nur eine atempause eingelegt hat reger
verkehr in den straßen reichlich angebot
in den markt teilen wenn da nicht die
türkei ein paar kilometer entfernt wäre
denn für ankara ist dieser kurdisch
regierte norden syriens ein haut von
terroristen entsprechend groß ist hier
die angst
die jungen leute werden auf jeden fall
gegen die invasion kämpfen aber was wird
aus den frauen und kinder
wer kann versucht wegzukommen aber wohin
kaum jemand hat arbeit oder geld
die selbstverwaltung im kurdischen
norden syriens wird von der bewaffneten
kurden mini cpg gesichert für die
amerikaner partner im kampf gegen den
terror der dschihadisten für die türkei
ein ableger der linken
terrororganisation pkk ankaras
staatsfeind nummer eins
seit jahren fordert staatspräsident
erdogan die einrichtung einer schutzzone
wie er es nennt in nordsyrien sein
wichtigstes ziel die kurdischen milizen
dort ausschalten
wir gehen in die nächste phase unserer
operation um eine 30 km eine
sicherheitszone an unserer südlichen
grenze einzurichten wir werden die
syrischen gebiete tel rifaat und man
beach von terroristen befreien
die präsidiale ankündigung löste letzte
woche hektische betriebsamkeit bei den
staatsnahen medien aus es wurde nach
kräften für die neue syrien offensive
getrommelt auf allen kanälen in allen
zeitungen als live-event an der grenze
oder mit truppen reportern in den
syrischen gebieten die schon bei 3 in
versionen zuvor besetzt worden war
erdogans kalkül der ukraine krieg hat
eine neue lage geschaffen ein günstiger
zeitpunkt um eigene militärische ziele
durchzusetzen
denn die türkei ist als vermittler jetzt
ein gefragter partner bei russen und bei
der nato das gilt es auszunutzen und
loszuschlagen
[Musik]
kritische beobachter wie die
journalisten der linken zeitung bürger
halten die bedrohung allerdings für
konstruiert kurdische milizen würden
zwar immer wieder türkische truppen
angreifen aber in syrien nicht auf
türkischem territorium
es ist immerhin irland und vorher gab es
von dort keinen ärger gegen uns anders
als bei den islamistischen dschihadisten
in idlib er wird direkt an unsere grenze
ein scharia staat errichtet quasi ein
zweites afghanistan
dagegen hat die türkische regierung
nichts einzuwenden
die gründe für erdogans sieben kassen
dürften eher zu hause liegen als in
syrien es läuft nicht rund seine
geldpolitik mit künstlich niedrigen
zinsen führt zum kursverfall die preise
explodieren und die verbraucher leiden
die folge erdogan und seine partei akp
stecken ein jahr vor der wahl in einem
allzeit umfragetief die menschen können
kaum noch ihre miete bezahlen die
inflation geht in richtung 100 prozent
hyperinflation
das land geht in den bankrott und er
versucht davon abzulenken
ob das diesmal gelingt ist fraglich
zwar kann erdogan auf den starken
nationalismus der türken und die anti
kurdischen gefühle im land bauen aber
die begeisterung für einen neuen feldzug
in syrien hält sich bei den bürgern eher
in grenzen
ich unterstütze das nicht klar wir
hatten immer probleme mit den kurden
auch in syrien aber wir müssen jetzt mal
an uns selbst denken wir haben hier
genug schwierigkeiten
unser regierungschef soll sich erstmal
um uns kümmern
nein ich bin dagegen weshalb weil das
geld dann weg ist der krieg da ist
kompliziert das kostet einen haufen geld
[Musik]
deutlich zu spüren ist angesichts der
wirtschaftskrise auch der zunehmende
unmut über die mehr als drei millionen
syrischen flüchtlinge im land
unsere bevölkerung braucht jetzt hilfe
was ist schon syrien die haben hier alle
vier handys während unsere jugend leidet
wenn ich ihnen dazu was sage dann werde
ich gleich abgeholt also sage ich lieber
nichts nur so viel die türkische jugend
hat dieses thema satt all diese syrer
die eroberung weiterer gebiete so hat
erdogan angekündigt werde auch platz für
die rückführung syrischer flüchtlinge
schaffen für die menschen jenseits der
grenze verheißt das nichts gutes sie
haben hier sehr konkrete vorstellungen
davon was die türkei mit ihnen vorhat
die wollen uns von hier vertreiben und
dann andere bevölkerung ansiedeln das
haben sie auch schon in afrika nähe
gemacht
besonders groß ist die furcht bei der
christlichen minderheit denn zu den
verbündeten der türken gehört die
sogenannte syrische nationale armee
unter ihnen sind zahlreiche
islamistische milizen die sind
berüchtigt für ihre jagd auf christen
wir beten für unser land und dafür dass
wir nicht vertrieben werden dass unsere
kirchen erhalten bleiben aber viele sind
schon gegangen
wohin europa wir wollen in sicherheit
leben
den menschen im kurdisch verwalteten
nordsyrien bleibt nur die hoffnung dass
russen oder amerikaner im letzten moment
druck auf ankara machen werden um eine
türkische offensive noch zu verhindern